On the 4th of July,
1854.
Okay.
And an outdoor park in Framingham,
Massachusetts,
which is 1520 miles west of Boston,
William Lloyd Garrison and the Massachusetts,
the Massachusetts,
the antislavery society built a stage.
They had a huge turnout
and garrison and his group performed an active abolitionist theater.
Anthony Burns had just been returned to slavery in Virginia,
Kansas.
Nebraska Act had just been passed and the month of May,
yeah.
Behind him on the stage,
huge,
uh,
array was first the insignia of the state of Virginia,
then an insignia of the state of Massachusetts,
a banner on one side.
That Red Redeem Massachusetts
hanging from that sign was something labeled the Crape of servitude.
Nothing very subtle about this.
And two flags were on either side of the rostrum,
one labeled Kansas and the other label Nebraska.
And behind garrison was a very large United States flag upside down.
Oh,
this was political theater
directed by a man who,
uh,
as you remember,
denounce political parties,
uh,
said that,
participation in political parties was complicit,
was complicity with slavery.
Garrison first read from scripture,
Old Testament Deuteronomy.
Then he proceeded to in three segments to burn documents.
Yeah.
He first held up and his hand,
what he said was the copy of the fugitive slave act,
which he burned in his hand with a lighted match through the ashes on the floor.
Stomped on the,
and the crowd shouted.
Amen.
Yeah.
Then he held in his hands the documents for the rendition.
You said it was a copy of the document for the rendition of Anthony Burns
returning burns as a fugitive slave to Virginia.
He burned that.
The ashes on the floor stomped on them and the crowd shouted.
Amen.
Then he pulled out a copy of the United States constitution,
which he announced as he had announced many times over.
And His newspaper,
the liberal writer,
he called it a quote,
covenant with death and agreement with hell.
So parish all compromisers with tyranny.
He burned it famously or infamously stomped on the ashes all over the stage and
the crowd shouted.
Amen.
The Kansas Nebraska Act had fueled
a political fervor that now could never be,
um,
bottled up again.
It could never be put back in its show.
Why?
Why was that future?
This Emma,
excuse me,
that Kansas Nebraska Act so troublesome.
Let me pick that up where I left you off the other day.
Now remember the Kansas Nebraska Act huts to simple resolutions,
although it came about through a heightening process.
The first was that it explicitly repealed the 36 30 parallel or Missouri
compromise line.
What northerners antislavery abolition this story,
even in some cases hardly aware of slavery.
Northerners had always referred to as the quote sacred pledge.
That sacred pledge was now 34 years old.
Everybody in the United States Congress,
I grown up with it.
It was a template.
It was an assumption,
not unlike you could name certain great resolutions or assumptions that became
almost standard parts of American political culture,
perhaps in your lifetime.
Certainly in my lifetime,
certain aspects of the new deal we thought
were basic American political assumptions like social security,
but recently that one got challenged.
You can think of others,
the right to collective bargaining of the Wagner act in the 1930 [inaudible].
You can think of other,
some would say Roe v Wade.
Some would say affirmative action,
so I'm going to say other aspects of our political culture born of the 1960s
some would say the 64 civil rights act,
et cetera.
I can't,
the Missouri compromise line as people imagine the slavery question in the West
had been seen by northerners as quote a sacred pledge that was not repealed
explicitly in this very sectionalized divided vote in the Kansas Nebraska Act to
set up the Kansas Nebraska territory.
The second part was of course a declaration that any state produced,
created from Kansas and Nebraska would be created on a principle of popular
sovereignty.
There would be a popular referendum at some stage and the territorial process to
be worked out later.
It past the U S Senate 37 to 14 that's in great part because the Kansas Nebraska
act became an absolute test of Democratic Party loyalty,
which Stephen Douglas demanded.
He didn't get all democrats just support it,
but he got most of them and the Whig party by 1864 and what was still a
fledgling two party system now greatly challenged by third party called the
American party or known more euphemistically as the know.
Nothing party or known more directly as the nativist party.
More on that in a moment is really challenging that third party system in a two
party system,
but it was that vote in the House that I showed you on a graphic the other day
that tells you the story.
It passed the House of Representatives one 13 to one 10 and a highly
sectionalized vote.
90% of all southerners on Kansas,
Nebraska voted for it.
64% of all northern people from free states voted against it.
The American,
the second American party system born out of the struggle over Jacksonian so
called Jacksonian democracy from the 1820s and the 30s into the forties and
early fifties was now disintegrated faster than most people even really realized
the effects of this.
We're quickly this,
the Kansas Nebraska Act now through open the vast expanse of what was left of
the Louisiana purchase to the possible expansion of slavery
second lane.
It will destroy the party forever
and and open a huge vacuum in American political culture for some kind of new
coalition,
some kind of new persuasion that would fill it about this great question of its
time,
the expansion of slavery and then more directly third,
it brought overnight the birth of the Republican Party,
the original Republican Party,
I hasten to a party form literally overnight in reaction to the Kansas Nebraska
Act.
It was often the first call,
the Anti Kansas party there three or four towns all over the Midwest and United
States repping Wisconsin,
Jackson,
Michigan,
and others that all claim to be the site of the birth of the Republican Party
and they all have their little monuments are the plaques and town squares and
parks to say they were the place where the first Republican Party meeting was
held,
but there were a part of public and party was really born amidst hundreds of
meetings across the north to discuss the Kansas Nebraska Act to react to it,
to figure out some way to politically resisted.
Okay.
That hell of a storm that Stephen Douglas had predicted is exactly what
happened,
but he didn't have any clue
the
direction or the ferocity of the political storm that this would cause to so
many northerners now who believed who for whom the American dream was mobility
in the west.
Availability of cheap,
if not free land in the West,
the possibility of the small farmer,
the small mechanic moving west and getting land in a society without slaves now
seem to be completely thrown up in the air.
If not denied.
I don't know what to really compare it to today.
That might shock people.
Something you assumed was just going to be there and tomorrow it's not.
It's just gone and you basically define the future of your children on it.
Lots of people.
Now I wondered,
you know what happened to the compromise of 1850 well that was a essentially
dead letter and what was born in that Republican part.
It what was born in those meetings and forms.
The Republican Party in the summer of 1854
was a theory and idea.
They called the slave power conspiracy air.
Actually,
it wasn't born there.
That's an old idea.
The idea of a
slave power.
Let me zoom on this a bit.
Oh cool.
I could become a techie before this course is over.
But the idea of a slave power,
this notion of a,
some kind of conspiracy or cadre and oligarchy,
a small number of great planters in the deep south and nevertheless had
tremendously disproportionate power over their own states,
over their own region.
And then in the Congress and in the Supreme Court in,
in,
in the presidency was an old idea.
I found it as early as the 1820s and an old article I once wrote where people
were actually is already using the term the slave power,
but it really crystallized in the 1850s.
This is a poster,
um,
one of hundreds,
thousands of posters from 1854,
uh,
calling for a meeting.
It doesn't even use the term Republican party anywhere.
Just calling people together.
It's in Chester,
Pennsylvania.
I think just calling people together to discuss the Kansas Nebraska act to
discuss what's really happened here and to discuss the slave power,
classic 19th century broad side with,
you know,
eight things going on at once in front of your eyes.
But the bold is print is reserved for the slave power.
Fear
conspiracy
come together,
watch out,
get ready.
The fear now you see,
think closely about this to northerners was now wait a second if for the Kansas
Nebraska Act is saying is that the Louisiana pertinent all the rest of the
Louisiana purchase is now open to the possible expansion of slavery.
Okay.
It's got to be rooted in a constitutional theory that probably is supporting
that Fifth Amendment,
which is the right to life,
liberty and property and the transport of that property anywhere you want.
So what's to stop someday somehow slaveholders from coming into Illinois,
Ohio,
New York,
Boston,
I seem a bit farfetched,
but editorial started appearing all over the north like this one from the New
York Post that predicted quote gangs of men and women chained together may yet
be seen now marching up or down Broadway or trembling in battery park.
What was born in that summer and especially that fall,
was the most rapid third party political coalition movement in all of American
history.
And if you want a prototype for any possibility of that kind any other time in
our political history,
this is it.
The Republican Party,
brand new,
not six months old.
We'll elect 100 people to the House of Representatives in the fall elections of
and they will begin to draw together a remarkable coalition.
They're going to draw a first,
a whole lot of old Whigs,
northern Whigs in particular,
who don't have any home anymore.
This is the old wig party of Henry Clay,
but it's also the old wig party that had a reformist element to it.
This was the old John Quincy Adams wing of the Whig party,
and there were some wigs who had become genuine abolitionist
in many states,
and they know we're looking for a real political home in which to plant their
flag.
I've not just free soil,
but a moral case against slavery.
You got the old free soilers.
The free soil party had existed in any 48 in the 1852 elections.
And remember I told you they liked it.
The web is it for people that the House of Representatives,
but more importantly,
that Republican party now had tremendous,
we're calling it now crossover,
aren't we?
Tremendous Crossover appeal to northern Democrat,
lifelong northern Democrats who will now break with Stephen Douglas,
break with popular sovereignty,
break with their own political lives and join a new free soil antislavery party.
David Wilmata,
the author of the Walmart provides all you'll remember from a week ago that
Pennsylvania Democrat who launched this idea during the debates in the Mexican
war,
the sit in any territory,
any state form from a territory gain from the Mexican war,
slavery shall never exist.
The basic free soil position.
In 1854,
David Wilma became a Republican.
This new political coalition,
fledgling as it was,
a lot of strange bedfellows here.
Guys who would just fought like hell with each other for years in the congress.
We're now kind of forming the same party.
They're forming it around a few key ideas.
One is this,
this notion,
this,
you know,
this idea of a slave power.
There has to be resisted now,
uh,
as a political force.
It has to be resisted as an expansion,
as migration forced.
It has to be resistant as a labor system.
It has to be resistant.
And secondly,
they are rooting their political future in radiology and what they're calling
quite explicitly now and they've rehearsed this many of them for some years and
antislavery interpretation of the constitution.
They're going to now really rehearse publicly the idea that yes,
slavery may be constitutionally where it already exist because slaves are
legally property.
Okay,
we've heard that for decades and they're going to say,
but the federal government has jurisdiction over territories.
It has jurisdiction over the district of Columbia,
and the slogan that flows from this idea of a of an anti slavery interpretation
of the Constitution is make freedom national slavery sectional.
That's slavery shall forever be.
They say a regional sectional local institution,
not a national institution,
which was an implicit way of saying the west shall be kept free for free labor
at all costs.
And then thirdly,
the Republican party is rooted and this is why it could become a coalition.
It's rooted in this cluster of ideas.
We've come to call here and Bruce Levine's book is terrific on this,
a free labor ideology,
a fear of concentrated power.
The defense of the individual,
the small man.
It was a fanfare for the common man,
the small farmer,
the small clerk,
the small,
small in the sense of he has nothing.
He may own nothing but he wants to own something.
It's the immigrant with nothing who wants to own a farm
and he must have,
at least in this America of it's boundless West,
he must have physical mobility,
geographical mobility,
and historians have come to define all of this.
Of course,
under a this,
this cluster of notions we call republicanism.
The belief that the United States was,
if not a democracy,
at least a republic
or the people rule or consent of a majority really counts.
And if that majority is increasingly becoming small farmers and clerks and
mechanics and a lot of them immigrants,
then oligarchies ought to be put on the run.
Whether those oligarchies are bankers or those oligarchies are made up of slave
holders.
This was in its birth and for the next six years,
one of the most potent political coalition ideologies this country has ever
seen.
Now what happens next?
What happens to this new coalition?
Okay.
Why are they going to be so threatening to the south?
This is in some ways it's going to become the planter,
elite southern slave holding classes,
greatest fear,
a genuine Yankee anti slavery,
northern political party after all the north now has close to pushing a two to
one advantage and population.
That is,
if we'd simply define that by free states.
Slave states.
No.
Okay.
Oh,
but a zoom back here,
maybe you've seen this picture before.
It's the,
uh,
it's Alyssa graph of the famous beating of Charles Sumner in the spring of 1856
on the floor of the u s Senate by Preston Brooks.
But how do we get to a scene in the u s senate of a southern Congressmen beating
the hell out of,
uh,
out of a Massachusetts senator beating him,
literally unconscious,
uh,
bloodying him on the floor of the Senate
while his fellow senators looked on and some of them in Glee,
there were 91 northern Democrats in the House of Representatives when they voted
on the Kansas Nebraska Act.
After the fall elections of 1854,
there were only 25 left.
Yeah.
This is a political see change happening and no one quite knows where it's going
yet.
And then that same year of 1854,
this nativist party,
they call themselves the American party,
a party that stood essentially for trying to stop Catholic,
namely Catholic immigration into the United States.
This was the,
this was the moment,
of course.
And you look around today,
we've got a huge debate going on about immigration,
and I won't go into that,
but you can see how it's clustering in parts of our political culture heighten
that six times over to the early 1950s,
the huge Irish migrations to the United States had just happened between the mid
1840s,
especially the late 1840 [inaudible] and about 1852 to 54.
This is the moment,
the historical moment of the terrible infamous potato famine in Ireland.
The native,
his party was anti-catholic,
anti-immigrant.
They believe the Catholicism would undermine American Protestant values and the
Protestant work ethic.
Um,
they believe that the United States of America ought to be a white Anglo Saxon
Protestant nation as it was in its founding.
They believed in a conspiracy of popery crazy as that may seem to some of us
today,
they believe that Catholics owed and demonstrated a higher loyalty to the pope
in Rome than they ever would in the United States to the United States
government,
and therefore Catholics could not be true.
Republicans,
I know.
Give me a break,
but it is what this party was rooted in
and man,
did they succeed?
Okay?
They're one huge electoral victories in the fall of 1854 particularly because
there's this new vacuum.
Now,
the Whig party is dead
by 1856 and the presidential election of 56 the nativists American party
candidate well went over 800,000 votes for the presidency.
More on that in a second,
the American party won 40 seats in the u s congress in 1854 they dominated a few
northern state legislatures.
They won the governorship of,
of,
of Massachusetts,
and a majority of its legislature.
It shocked people.
It's shocked.
Some northern Democrats who weren't comfortable.
Well,
this nativism,
the variance of this nativism to become Republicans instead
now out west,
of course,
what's going to happen to Kansas and Nebraska.
Kansas now became the object of tremendous migration.
It was nothing but a series of frontier settlements in 1855 but pop,
but but large numbers of people began to go there.
These were the so called squatters.
Squatters or farmers.
Yeah,
but immediately it became a contest between how many Yankees and northerners
would actually get there and try to make the place free soil and how many
southerners would actually get there with slaves and try to produce a pro
slavery constitution.
Kansas became the great testing ground of popular sovereignty.
Immigrant aid societies is emerge is especially in New England,
one famous one that had a lot of financial backing behind it called the New
England immigrant aid society.
They recruited settlers.
They raised money.
They paid people's way out to Kansas.
In some cases,
Kansas now became a kind of symbol and reality
out on its border.
Of course,
as eastern border was the state of Missouri,
which was a slave state,
and Missourians being a flock across the border into Kansas,
taking land
by March of 1855 only one year,
less than a year,
11 months after the passage of the Kansas Nebraska Act,
they held their first election for a territorial legislature in the territory of
Kansas,
an estimated 5,000 so called border Ruffins or that meant Missourians flocked
over into Kansas for a day or two to vote
the census.
They took a rapid census in the early spring of 1855 and Kansas recorded 2,905
eligible voters in all of Kansas and that territorial legislature election,
6,307 people voted
way more than half of the people registered to vote.
Voted
Yeah.
Uh,
something was wrong.
They elected a pro slavery legislature,
adopted a pro slavery and a constitution overnight and free soilers cried foul,
formed their own attempt at a government that summer
and by January of 1856 the beginning of the next year,
in a sense.
In essence,
there were two fledgling territorial governments in Kansas,
one free soil,
one pro slavery,
and it was then that spring of 1856 that what we call bleeding Kansas.
This border front tier civil war,
this village against village,
a river ravine against river ravine broke out before it played out over about a
year and a half,
about 250 people would be killed.
Many of them in nighttime raids and vigilante violence and millions and
treasure.
I will come back to John Brown later next week.
In fact,
our friend John Brown from upstate New York or somebody friend he wasn't easy to
be friends with,
had already sent out some of his sons.
More on that later in,
John Brown arrived himself and the winter of 1856 John Brown,
a genuine radical,
deeply religious old testament abolitionist who went to Kansas.
Make no mistake to make Kansas free and to kill slave holders if necessary,
and what he believed was a justifiable war.
That's spring.
John Brown with his band of men was traveling along the road when he got news of
the beating of Charles Sumner incentive.
What happened in the Senate is the Charles Sumner,
the radical abolitionist senator from Massachusetts,
one of only a tiny handful,
actually one of only two or three,
three or four real card carrying abolitionist if we wouldn't want to call them
that,
who had seats in the u s Senate,
some Nerd,
deeply well-educated,
classically educated.
Harvard man began his political life as a so cold conscience wig in
Massachusetts.
He got elected to the U S Senate in the fervor over the Mexican war and in the
fervor over the expansion of slavery in its first few years in the Senate from
(840) 950-5152 a they had a virtual gag on him.
Anytime someone who tried to get the floor,
that's when on for about four years,
there were all kinds of parliamentary maneuvers that the opposition could use to
prevent him from speaking and one or abolitionists rhetoric in the halls of the
u s senate.
But with time he got a position that is a,
a place where he could speak
in the sentence calendar
and he did.
He delivered a speech earlier that Spring called the crime against Kansas.
He delivered it in March,
1856.
It took him about six hours.
It was later published in a pamphlet form.
It's about 35,
40 pages.
It was the classic free soil argument of what was now the Republican Party.
And Sumner was by now of course,
a Republican.
Uh,
he made all the arguments about a slave power conspiracy and,
and antislavery interpretation of the constitution.
He argued deeply into the,
into the,
into that cluster of ideas we call free labor ideology.
But then he lays this beach over and over with personal attacks on southerners,
personal attacks on southern slave holders.
He singled out,
especially Senator Andrew Butler,
South Carolina,
and he used Butler's alleged fathering of children by a slave woman as
representative of what Sumner said was a common practice across the south.
You could not imagine laying a bigger taboo and your fellow southern senators.
And then this one,
he described a Butler as quote,
a Don Quixote who had taken the harlots slavery as his mistress.
And then he went on and on with that.
He was weird southern
instead of shouting at him and Sumner just enjoyed it and went on.
Many of them walked out,
but he'd already had copies of the speech printed.
He had speech copies of the speech on the street within a few days
in the audience.
That day,
sitting up in the balcony was a member of the US House of Representatives named
Preston Brooks,
who was the nephew of Senator Butler.
About a week after this event
may have been two weeks,
Butler decided that he was going to have honor.
He was going to exercise a,
um,
an act of honor and revenge.
A deeply rooted in what he believed was the old south sense of honor.
He had thought about challenging Somner to a duel,
but duals by this point in time were highly illegal.
Even though people did get challenged.
I read my colleague Join Freeman on this.
They're still challenging each other to duels all the time and 1850s,
well a lot of times,
but he decided against challenging song or do a dual.
Instead,
we thought it would take a sort of plan B.
He would meet Sumner at his desk with a cane and try to kill him.
Any Dude,
uh,
Brooks took a cane to Sumner.
Sumner was sitting at his desk,
literally signing copies of the crime against Kansas speech to be sent out and
he got trapped in the desk.
We're told he couldn't get out of it and Brooks does kept banging on his head
over and over,
digitally bloodied him and done consciousness and Sumner fell on the floor.
And they're all kinds of stories.
And the effect is lithograph tries to capture it,
although I'm not sure you can see it very well.
And all kinds of stories about senators,
especially southerners gathering around saying,
you know,
holding back,
holding me back as they smiled and watch something or bleed on the floor.
And finally somebody grabbed Brooks is Cain and said,
you know,
that's probably enough.
Okay.
Any by any definition.
This was an assault with a deadly weapon.
This was an assault and batteries and attempted murder.
Preston Brooks went back to the House of Representatives,
tendered his resignation.
Instead,
he would go back home to South Carolina and submit himself to the people of his
district.
And you did.
And they overwhelmingly reelected him.
He also received more than 100 commemorative canes in the mail.
Some of what you can see today at the Caroliniana Library in Columbia,
South Carolina.
This became of course a cause Celeb,
um,
uh,
brutal example now of the way in which compromise was being ruined.
Middle Realm for moderation was perhaps being destroyed.
Violence at broken out all over Kansas.
Violence had not broken out in the U S Senate.
It led many people to a fearful set of expressions.
There literally hundreds of these in the press.
Uh,
this is one from William Cullen Bryant who wrote in the New York evening post
after the news broke of the beating of Sumner.
I quote him,
violence rains in the streets of Washington.
Violence has now found his way into the Senate.
Chamber.
Violence lies in wait all over the navigable rivers in the,
all the railways of Missouri to obstruct those who pass from,
from the free states into Kansas.
Violence overhangs,
the frontiers of that territory,
like a storm cloud charged with hail,
enlightening violence has carried election after election in that territory.
In short,
violence is the order of the day.
The North needs to be pushed to the wall by it and this plot will succeed if the
people of the free states are as apathetic as the slave holders are.
Insolent.
It was news of the beating of Sumner on the floor of the Senate that apparently
made John Brown snap and within 48 hours,
he led the what's called the Pottawattamie creek massacre,
um,
where he murdered five pro slavery advocates in cold blood with broad swords and
the dark of the night.
We will return to John Brown's exploits next week.
Now
that year was though a presidential election year and the problem is still just
laying there out on the landscape what is to happen
with Kansas,
Nebraska,
what's to be done with bleeding Kansas,
what's to be done with,
oops,
sorry.
Now in that election of 1856,
this is terribly important.
Just to note for a moment,
the Republican Party will mount it's first effort at the presidency and it all
but in an all but one is a never happened in American history until then.
It's never happened since a new third party that comes so close to winning the
platform of the Republican Party in 1856 was as if anything slightly more
radical than it had been in two years earlier.
And those congressional elections of 1854 they took a staunch stand about
slavery expansion.
They took a staunch Stan and keeping Kansas free.
Yeah,
they announced directly that they would quote,
destroy Slavery Wherever Federal Jurisdiction,
rain
for president.
They ran John,
see Fremont,
young,
dashing,
romantic,
heroic type.
He had been one of the great surveyors and explorers of the West.
He was already known by the nickname of the Pathfinder and he was the first
senator from the state of California.
Okay.
He's also the son in law of Thomas Hart Benton and a very powerful now
Republican from Missouri.
He,
he was well married,
well connected and good looking.
They centered their campaign,
they borrowed some nature's own language.
Okay.
And they centered their campaign on what the Republican Party itself now called
the crime against Kansas.
They were all so for tariffs for the transcontinental railroad across the West
and so on.
The American party known as the know nothings by the way,
because in their origins,
if you didn't know this about the know nothings in their origins,
the American nativist party tried to maintain a secrecy.
They were kind of secret society at first and when asked who they were and how
they met and what they were for,
their original members would always say they knew nothing.
So whenever you hear that term,
no,
nothing ism in American politics.
If somebody throws it,
you know,
if Chris Matthews throws that term off at you,
showing off his political history now and usually means nativism or it means
some kind of third party phenomenon,
the know nothings nominated that you're Millard Fillmore pre former president.
He'd been the president during the compromise of 1850 it was a very strange
choice and the know nothings,
we're now in some trouble because of this powerful new Republican coalition,
which is managing now to draw some of the native is into them because it turns
out some nativists.
We're actually more afraid of the slave holding oligarchy.
Then there were of this Catholic conspiracy,
if they had to choose conspiracies,
they were a little more frightened to slave holders and pups.
The Democrats when safe,
they chose a largely in competent James Buchanan to run for president.
He was from Pennsylvania,
you know,
kind of lower north.
He was known to have very strong ties to the south and to be a co what
Republicans are already calling a doe phase,
which meant a northerner was southern sympathies
and he had been in the United States ambassador to Britain during the Kansas
Nebraska crisis.
So he had never voted on it.
He had no position to defend.
It was a highly sectionalized election.
Buchanan carried every slave state except Maryland.
Okay.
And then you carried New Jersey,
Pennsylvania,
Indiana,
Illinois,
and California.
The Democratic Party was still a national party.
Okay.
Fremont,
the Republican carried
the rest of the free states and New England decisively,
Fremont and Fillmore together and fill more of a native nativist candidate.
Got 850,000 votes.
Buchanan about 1.8 million.
Fremont about 1.51 point 6 million.
I wouldn't know I had 1.3 million.
Yeah.
If the native,
his party had not been in this election,
and if most of the nativist had gone to Fremont,
the Republican or even two thirds of them,
Fremont would have won the presidency.
This antislavery northern coalition of free soil advocates came very close.
They would even call it in its wake,
a victory within defeat for such a brand new political party.
No out in Kansas,
there's still trying to hold elections.
One corrupt fraudulent election after another you can and took office.
In the spring of 57 he appointed a new governor for the territory of Kansas
named Robert Jay Walker,
whose job it was going.
He was a solid Pennsylvania Democrat,
but nevertheless said I will go out there and enforce popular sovereignty.
We're going to have a true free ballad in Kansas.
Popular sovereignty is still gonna work.
The trouble was popular.
Sovereignty was now dead in the water.
It was tainted at best
and the election of delegates to yet another attempt at a state constitutional
writing convention in Kansas in the fall of 1857 the free soilers boycotted the
election.
So at La,
Compton,
Kansas,
and hence the term [inaudible] constitution,
a pro slavery constitutional convention met with the free soilers all boycotting
and they drafted no mistake,
a pro slavery.
It protected slavery and the right to slave ownership eternally forever in the
state of Kansas.
It excluded from residents in the state of Kansas.
Any free negroes.
Yeah,
and it said that it could not be amended in any way.
For seven years,
this process had taken drastic liberties with the ID of popular sovereignty,
which is you'll remember was the idea.
You're supposed to have a popular referendum and just let the vote determine
whether slavery shall exist.
This governor Walker lost control of the territory,
violence,
continued terrible violence
and walker came back to Washington,
urged his own president who had appointed him to not support this La Compton
constitution.
He said,
it's just,
it's not right.
It's just to fraudulent.
It was boycotted by half of the people,
probably more than half the people,
and Buchanan made a fateful decision.
He said,
nope.
They've had their popular sovereignty.
They've had their constitution right and convention.
If the free show,
this show's not participate.
That's the way it goes.
And Buchanan took the La Compton Constitution,
the congress,
and asked for it's approval of Kansas as a slave state.
Buchanan took huge political risks here and didn't prep for all practical
purposes,
apparently know what he was doing.
And here we begin.
To see now the breakup,
a tearing apart now of even the Democratic Party,
cause none other than Steven Douglas,
father of popular sovereignty,
author of the Kansas Nebraska Act.
Uh,
the man who had,
who had,
who would push that acts through,
went to Buchanan and said,
no sir,
you cannot support the comp,
the constitution.
It's a fraudulent constitution.
The majority of the people in that territory are probably free soil.
You can't do this.
He broke with his own president and it would be disastrous for the Democratic
Party.
Uh,
Compton Constitution was not accepted by the congress.
Now
the dred Scott decision,
which came down that same spring of 1857 and the immediate aftermath of
Buchanan's election,
and there's old dread,
not a great picture of him,
but see,
the only photograph we have of dred Scott,
the dred Scott decision also came down in the midst of a major American
depression.
The so called panic of 1857 broke out that very spring.
Same time as the Buchanan is being inaugurated,
the Compton Constitution is being forged out in Kansas.
The dred Scott decision is going to be announced.
The country is falling into a horrible economic panic.
There are many causes of it.
I wish I had the time.
Actually.
I'm going to save the panic of 1857 because it sets up
Lincoln and Douglas and 58 59 for me later,
but I want to leave you.
I've got three minutes.
Two minutes.
Okay,
great.
Would this fateful supreme court case,
many people like to say the worst supreme court decision in all of American
history,
but I suspect you can get up a debate over that.
I think we've had a couple others.
I won't name them.
Yeah.
Who was dred Scott.
This man who was an old man.
By the time the Supreme Court ruled on him and put his name forever into
American history as a symbol was born a slave and 1795 in Virginia.
He had moved to Missouri and the 1820s with his master,
a man,
his original master,
his name was Peter Blow.
It was then later on by physician,
a doctor named John Emerson.
Emerson was an army surgeon and Emerson traveled from Missouri all over the
upper Midwest and into what then was the great plains as an army surgeon working
at army camps and basis.
Dred Scott went with him is his personal servant.
They travel to Illinois and Minnesota.
Dred Scott lived with his master from 1834 to 1838,
four years with Dr. Emerson on various kinds of military bases,
especially in Minnesota,
a free territory.
At one point,
dred Scott tried to buy his own freedom in Minnesota.
It wasn't allowed to do it.
He married a free black woman named Harriet while he was in Minnesota.
Okay.
Four years,
residents on free soil and attempt to buy his own freedom,
marries a free black woman.
Emerson brought him back to Missouri in 1838 and through,
uh,
an intricate series of events for the next five to six years,
not the least of which was Missouri is a very divided place,
especially St Louis.
A group of antislavery folk gathered around dred Scott and tried to help him sue
for his freedom.
1846.
They moved his through local courts.
In the first decision was that a local court,
because of his residence and free soil for four years,
gave dred Scott his freedom.
That court decided the case in 1850
it was then appealed by the state of Missouri.
She was really worried about this case to the Missouri Supreme Court and the
Missouri Supreme Court by a decision of two to one
ruled.
No,
no,
no.
On appeal,
dread Scott's freedom would be denied that he had did.
He did not have the right to his freedom because of residents on free soil.
Then again with the help of an antislavery group and even his own owner,
believe it or not,
they push this appeal to the u s supreme court.
Dr. Emerson was gone.
Dread was now owned by a man named John Sanford and hence the cases called
Sanford versus Scott.
Scott's case came before the u s supreme court as early as 1854 it got on the
docket.
It would not be decided for two and a half years.
Most people didn't even know this was happening.
I'll leave you here.
Only three days after James Buchanan was inaugurated president
having just only narrowly defeated this new Republican coalition news,
broken Washington of something called the dred Scott decision,
and it would electrify the political culture of the country.
It will fuel this Republican Party antislavery coalition as much as in some
places,
as much as the Kansas Nebraska act ever had,
and it will inspire Abraham Lincoln to run for the Senate.
That's it for now.